it stalks the woods during the coldest
and harshest months of the year played
with an insatiable hunger of immense
size and speed the Windigo monster of
Native American lore has become one of
the most notorious flesh eaters of all
time the Windigo legend teaches us about
Native American spiritual beliefs and
social values and has three major
symbolic interpretations the incarnation
of winter the embodiment of hunger and
the personification of selfishness both
spiritual and physical
and then there's cannibalism i'm dr.
emily Zarqa and this is monstrum
the wind ego has clawed its way into
popular culture appearing in TV shows
like supernaturally charmed and marvel
comics its terrorized audiences and
movies this Indian scouts told me a
curious story
weendigo it's an old Indian myth from
the north and video games
rod one and even in My Little Pony
episode
[Music]
Wendigos leave the girls i feel
confident saying that this creatures
gone mainstream but almost all of these
portrayals fail to capture the complete
history or even the original traits of
the wind ego the wind ego legend
originates with indigenous people who
belong to the Algonquian language family
they say it's a giant humanoid cannibal
who can move at an incredibly fast speed
the wind eco is astonishingly tall with
razor-sharp teeth and claws and lips
that are often chewed ragged or gone
completely they have a heart made of ice
and despite their unending hunger for
human flesh they remain emaciated it
shrieks and can run across treetops and
its presence may be preceded by a foul
odor or a sudden snowstorm almost all
wind egos begin as humans and once
transformed it has no gender but how
does one become a wind ego
the most common way is by eating human
flesh but there are others including
dreaming of the wind ego it is also
believed that you can become a wind ego
without physically transforming someone
who is in a state of inner turmoil might
be a risk of becoming one some
communities believe it can be caused by
spiritual imbalance or by choosing to
prioritize the self over the community
since the lure of the Algonquian
people's is largely shared through oral
tradition there are several variations
of the wind ego but the origins of the
legend undoubtedly began with the
indigenous tribes that lived in the
northern Woodlands Atlantic coast and
Great Lakes regions the Algonquian
language family is one of the largest
native linguistic groups in North
America and includes these groups among
others because of this widespread
distribution the Windigo has many names
Spelling's and pronunciations there are
more than 37 names for it that begin
with W here we use the spelling that
more accurately reflects the Cree and
Ojibwe pronunciations and the one that
appears more commonly in indigenous
authored texts regardless of how it's
spelt there is something that can help
explain the wendi-go legend climate and
geography all of the communities that
share the
Diigo myth experience long harsh winters
with heavy snowfall freezing
temperatures and a lack of resources the
fear of starvation was a very real thing
this encourages people to stick together
both a practical and necessary means of
survival the Windigo on the other hand
thrives in the winter and can travel in
blizzards it hunts for those who are
separated from the group or who leave
the safety of their homes the threat of
cannibalism is embodied by the Windigo
fear is a powerful motivator and this
story spooked people into sharing food
resources during the winter and
preparing adequate food storages during
the rest of the year so you know you
wouldn't have to venture out into that
blizzard and get eaten by a shrieking
wind ego the first written mention of
the Windigo occurred in 17th century
Jesuit records which coincides with
Europeans entering into the fur trade
the North American fur trade boom in the
18th and 19th centuries men even more
trappers were traveling to present-day
Canada the claws and vicious appetite of
the Windigo
along with the idea that a human could
transform into one reminded the
Europeans of a similar legend of their
own the werewolf
through trade community and marriage a
cross-cultural exchange of ideas
including monsters occurred a Jesuit
priests compared the European monster to
the wind egos similar canine hunger
saying it makes them so ravenous for
human flesh that they pounced upon women
children and even men like veritable
werewolves and devour them in Malaysia
sleep with associations like that it
makes sense how these two legendary
creatures overlap today and by most
Windigo depictions vary wildly from the
original you might have seen the Windigo
depicted as a stag human hybrid a human
with antlers or even with Ram horns for
ears there is no evidence of this in all
the Algonquian people's versions the
only animal the wind ego is associated
with in some stories is the Apple in
fact wind ego can translate as Apple or
cannibal depending on the dialect which
kind of makes sense given that owls do
eat flesh and are off
seen as omens of death the image of the
antlered Windigo seen in Hannibal
and Pet Sematary actually originates in
the film Wendigo
[Applause]
[Music]
the director Larry Fessenden merged a
story he was told as a child with the
scary stories to tell in the dark
version of the Windigo
itself adapted from another authors
interpretation Fessenden admits that he
didn't even do research on the Windigo
until after he made the movie but the
image is so foreign and striking it
continues to appear in movies art in
other pop culture texts the Windigo has
appeared in another venue the courtroom
in 1897 a windy go killing trial it
became a landmark case for early
Canadian law when an Ojibwe man was
found guilty of manslaughter for
shooting someone he believed to be a
windy go in his culture killing a windy
go was acceptable but his court
conviction confirmed that Canadian
common law applied to indigenous
communities even if they had no
knowledge of its existence in late 19th
and early 20th centuries a handful of
other indigenous people were similarly
convicted of murder for killing people
they deemed windy goes windy goes showed
up in another unlikely place psychiatry
in the 1920s and 30s
Wendigo psychosis a culture bound mental
illness was set to be a disorder that
drove people to cannibalism or
cannibalistic thoughts but in the 1970s
this diagnosis was brought into question
and no subject with a supposed condition
has ever been studied today most
scholars reject it completely like all
monsters we need to recognize the
origins of the creature even as it
continues to change and grow in other
traditions whether it's a Hulk battling
at Yeti s quindi go in the woods or
finding the cure to tuberculosis in
eating human flesh
greater significance and arguably
enjoyment can be found by recognizing
the creatures original purpose the
Windigo is largely popular today because
it represents a violation of a human
code don't kill one another and
certainly don't eat them if you do but
it's more than that
the Windigo is a warning about what
could happen
individual forgoes the collective for
their own survival the wendi-go is above
all a lesson in excess and a
manifestation of the anxieties that
emerge in the harsh realities of winter
and how to survive it
hint don't eat other people do you have
a favorite monster let me know in the
comments and don't forget to subscribe
godless off snap the Windigo has
appeared do you have a favorite monster
[Music]